well an end of summer surge is
disrupting the Biden administration's
claims that illegal border crossings are
dropping preliminary data reportedly
shows border patrol arrests in August
jumped to over a hundred and seventy
seven thousand that's up 30 percent for
the second month in a row by the way at
least 91 000 migrant families were
arrested at the border smashing the
previous record from 2019. joining me
now former Chief of United States border
patrol Ronald villagiello thank you
Ronald for talking to us you know these
inflated numbers come as the Biden
Administration rolled out these new
restrictions and entry opportunities and
with all of these additional arrests 91
000 in fact part of family units which
happen to be the largest demographic of
illegal migrants during the Trump
Administration and their touting numbers
are going down when it's actually quite
the opposite it seems
no we've been in this crisis since the
beginning of this Administration they
made terrible choices about our the
policies on our Southwest border which
has encouraged you know tens and
thousands of people to come from the
third world from all over the world
actually uh to come to our Southwest
border that's because of the choices
that they've made uh they ended the
remain in Mexico program and this is
what the results are we're seeing it
from the beginning of this
Administration uh everybody was worried
about what was going to happen at the
end of title 42
um the the numbers were muted after that
because why because they've moved the
illegal traffic to the ports of entry
and we still have thousands of people
crossing the border illegally every
night we have thousands of people
getting away from the border patrol
every single 24 hours and it's just been
encouraged by the choices that this
Administration has made yeah uh the
Biden Administration repeatedly points
to a decrease in Crossing at the
southern Border in May and June and they
use that as a key indicator apparently
that it's the latest post title 40 two
border policies in place that are
actually working and obviously that
narrative is clearly being undercut as
the numbers are surging back up let's
play this sound from Debbie lesko On the
Border Surge and hear what it's really
like since the president doesn't bother
to visit there
I imagine the cartels think that it's to
their advantage to put through more
family units and of course that leads to
more risk for the women and children to
be raped and abused it also leads to the
recycling of children that we know the
cartels do this is just a disaster
President Biden's job performance by the
way on border security uh 33 percent
approve so obviously the nation is
watching they are not visiting the
Border Kamala Harris might as well just
throw in the towel on her hole trying to
find a root cause to the Border I don't
think she knows where the border is so
what what say you on what's next I mean
title 42 was working and now it's not
because it's no longer in place after
this Administration took it down
good point What's Next more of the same
you know with the Senate and Democratic
hands with the president who cares
nothing about the chaos at the border
and the people who live there like the
congresswoman from a border state they
don't care about what's going on they
prefer this chaos over the control that
they had when they took over when this
Administration took over we had 45-year
lows in illegal migration across the
Southwest border that's left less depth
less threats less destruction of the
Border environment so this is what they
prefer and think about it 33 nobody
voted for this nobody asked for the
border to be so out of control and to
make these weird and unbelievable
choices that they made about the policy
they've just encouraged people to come
there think about it it wasn't that long
ago this would be the slowest time of
the year on the Southwest border because
of the extreme temperatures that are
that occur in places like Arizona and
Deep South Texas but people are choosing
to bring their families into the United
States at record numbers why because
they know they're going to be released
by this Administration and they're going
to be on on the economy and they're
going to come to every city and town in
the United States putting a burden on
law enforcement putting a burden on
public health care in our schools yeah I
mean in in all these cities in
Democratic cities I mean look at New
York City you've got people moving in
living for free and taking over uh parks
that should be for our children in
Massachusetts they've had to call up the
National Guard to keep up with migrants
as protests rage on there
um and and other democratic-led cities
all across the country are dealing with
higher crime rates this is what we're
bringing into America it's awful uh
former border patrol Chief Ronald
vitiello thank you very much for talking
to us we appreciate it
thank you happy labor day you too hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else